I reject outright the idea that people
have the right to tell me which words in
the English language I may and may not
use
um so the first way you fight back is By
ignoring it
right so
go ahead and use whatever words
pop into your head if they express what
you wanted to say
then use them and the other way to fight
back is to provide making fun of them
and I find that with uh the progressive
left that's the one thing they can't
take
um they don't mind it if you call them
names and get angry
um and and seem mean and they don't even
mind it when you fight back with the
same kind of tactics that they use like
oh we're going to ban all this language
but they hate to be laughed at